so liebe Zuschauer leiden sie auch noch
unter Schlafentzug ich jedenfalls habe
letzten Montag quasi durchgemacht vor
dem Fernseher um live dabei zu sein wenn
mitten in der Nacht der große Durchbruch
beim asylgipfel im Kanzleramt verkündet
wird ha das hat sich gelohnt bis bis
2:45 Uhr hat's gedauert und das Ergebnis
des Gipfels ist äm okay Olaf Scholz sagt
sehr historisch ich würde sagen okay z.B
das die Kommunen jetzt pro Asylbewerber
7500 € kriegen einiges geht in die
richtige Richtung bei anderen Maßnahmen
wird sich zeigen was sie bringen umso
wichtiger dass man diesen mühsam
errungenen Kompromiss dann auch
gemeinsam positiv verkauft hat super
geklappt für genau 3 Minuten dieses
Papier reicht natürlich nicht aus das
ist nicht der große Wurf nicht
zufriedenstellend es braucht mehr
braucht es noch mehr einiges fehlt bei
weitem nicht ausreichend schwerer Fehler
eine Enttäuschung herzlichen
Dank dafür nicht mein Gott schon wieder
Parteitaktik statt gemeinsam Probleme
anpacken die unionsministerpräsidenten
haben doch den Kompromiss mit
ausgehandelt um ihn anschließend Scheiße
zu finden aber dafür gab es einen
amtlichen Anschiss Freunde und zwar vom
Sturm Geschütz der FDP ja genau
von von von Agnes Flag zimmermann
was mir wirklich auf den Keks geht wir
hatten ein migrationsgipfel da sitzt der
Kanzler hören sie gut zu her gädchen sie
sind auch gleich dran da sitzt der
Kanzler da sitz die Ministerpräsidenten
zusammen und das einzige was kommt ein
Morgen später es wird
gesödert wie schrecklich alles wieder
war wow strcki on fire oder zurecht
meine Top Story am Dienstag Morgen war
gar nicht der Asylkompromiss sondern ein
angeblicher putch Versuch von hend wüst
gegen Friedrich
märzes CDU putch das sind alles
verheerende Signale Scholz lässt
ausrichten dass er die Opposition in der
Migrationsfrage gar nicht braucht und
dann beerdigt der Beleidigte Fritze März
auch noch den Armen deutschlandpakt ja
der deutschlandpakt ist tot meine Damen
und
Herren er war doch noch so jung keine
CDU Gespräche mehr mit dem Kanzler über
nichts und zw wegen
bitte nicht wegen Deutschland weswegen
denn dann ich habe jedenfalls nicht die
Absicht eine Mitverantwortung zu
übernehmen für dieses Problem und mit
diesem Problem dann in die Europawahl im
nächsten Jahr zu gehen das findet mit
uns und mit mir liebe Freundin und
Freunde nicht statt ja sorry mein Fehler
es geht gar nicht ums Land es geht um
die CDU bei den nächsten Wahlen ja man
musste auch mal an sich denken finde ich
alle wollen jetzt oder fast alle wollen
jetzt grundsätzlich mehr abschieben
abschieben
äh Migration steuern und begrenzen sagen
alle nur das wie also die konkrete
Umsetzung ist eben sehr komplex in dem
Rechtsstaat der wir ja hoffentlich
bleiben wollen der eigentliche Schlüssel
sind ohnehin migrationsabkommen aber die
dauern halt und bis dahin wollen wir
wohl unattraktiver werden damit weniger
kommen Prinzip Abschreckung und da
laufen auch schon ein paar ganz
vielversprechende Experimente z.B stehen
im Grenzgebiet zu Österreich jetzt große
Monitore auf denen rund um die Uhr Olaf
Scholz reden laufen und wir müssen über
das was getan werden muss reden damit
wir den Zug nicht verpassen nicht auf
dem falschen gleich landen sondern den
Richter Richter den richtigen das
Richtige und wer da länger zuhört
verliert oft das Interesse und geht
wieder nach Hause ne klar ist es ein
Problem dass fast jeder der es hier hin
schafft am Ende auch bleiben darf genau
deswegen hat die Runde im Kanzler
beschlossen dass Asylverfahren von
Behörden und vor total unterbesetzten
Gerichten schneller durchgeführt werden
soll sehr gut das heißt die feinen Damen
und Herren Richter müssen sich halt mal
beeilen Gas geben hinne machen wie kam
diese News aus dem Kanzleramt bei denen
so an
[Musik]
was
ich glaube er fand es nicht
gut so außerdem bekämpfen wir die
sogenannten pullfaktor die
bundeseinheitliche Bezahlkarte Start
Bargeld für Asylbewerber soll kommen
also erstmal kommt nicht Die Bezahlkarte
sondern eine Arbeitsgruppe die sich bis
Ende Januar überlegen darf wie das geht
und ob das geht aber immerhin ist ein
Anfang solche Bezahlkarten gab es
übrigens schon und zwar als Pilotprojekt
in Sachsen Anhalt aber die Discounter
haben dem Landrat eine Abfuhr erteilt
günstig Einkaufen nicht möglich rund 100
Läden im Süden von SachsenAnhalt sind
dabei vom Friseur bis zur Feinkost
käseecke haben dies gut die Asylbewerber
im Süden von Sachsen anhaltu Shoppen in
der Fromagerie Savo vivre da gibt's
einen fantastischen mittelalten gruer so
der arme Landrat da musste mit jedem
einzelnen Laden verhandeln das kein Witz
Bezahlkarte bedeutet in Wirklichkeit
riesen verwaltungsaufand aber wer weiß
vielleicht klappt's ja versuch macht
klug und genau dasselbe gilt übrigens
auch für die Idee Asylverfahren in
Drittstaaten durchzuführen z.B in Ruanda
ja ist ja plötzlich in aller Munde und
der sogenannte
ruandaap so und das war ja für mich die
Überraschung des asylgipfels dass neben
den unionsleuten plötzlich auch Winfried
Kretschmann für die Drittstaaten Lösung
ist als grüner totaler Schock für die
grüne Basis die fragen sich jetzt
angesichts der neuen Härte was kommt als
nächstes kann ich ihn sagen dieser Spot
ihre
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung ist viel zu voll
da kennen wir Schwaben ein altes
Hausmittel einfach die Heizung in der
Bude brutal runterdrehen jedes Grad
weniger reduziert den migrationdruck das
war's von mir mir ist kalt ich gehe nach
Hause die Grünen wir sind jetzt auch
gegen
Flüchtlinge
Jamann
ja Nachricht des Tages die Grünen heute
in Hessen aus der Regierung geflogen es
ist einfach nicht ihr ja aber zurück zum
Ruanda Modell vielleicht ist das
langfristig die Lösung leider wird den
Bürgern aber auch hier suggeriert der
erste Flieger nach Ruanda könnte quasi
übermorgen starten dabei gibt's noch
jede Menge offene Fragen die britische
Regierung versucht das mit Ruanda schon
seit 2 Jahren ohne Erfolg weil es ihn
Gerichte verbieten Stichwort
rechtsstaatliche Verfahren und was sagen
überhaupt die Menschen in Ruanda wir
schalten mal live nach Kigali zu unserem
Afrika Korrespondenten Alexander
wipbrecht Alexander wie kommt die
drittstaatenlösung denn so an im
Drittstaat super ne also ehrlich jetzt
die freuen sich riesig dass wir an Sie
gedacht haben ich habe hier mit
ruandischen Regierungsvertretern
gesprochen und die sagen klar wär es
schön wenn die Deutschen uns freorher
gefragt hätten wegen ihrer Flüchtlinge
aber ja jetzt ist es halt mal so wir
haben zwar schon den Deal mit England
aber da kommt ja nur auf ein paar mehr
auch nicht an macht die Antilope nicht
fett wie man hier sagt
ne der Regierungssprecher meinte sag
ruhig den Italienern und Griechen auch
noch wenn wir helfen können jederzeit
super nett kann Ruanda sich das denn
leisten hallo 6,8% Wirtschaftswachstum
letztes Jahr 6,8 oder wie Robert hab
sagen
würde Randa ist ein afrikanisches
Vorzeigeland niedrige Korruption rate
hoher akademikergrad dabei nicht mal so
groß wie Brandenburg im Grunde ein
bisschen wie unser Saarland halt nur
erfolgreich und schön ja aber deswegen
können wir nicht unsere Probleme bei
denen vor die Tür legen
unbedingt können wir das die Ruanda
gucken ja auch Nachrichten und wissen
wie prekär die Lage in Deutschland ist
im Fernsehen wird hier schon Geld
gesammelt damit bei uns das 49 € Ticket
nicht teurer wird ja die wollen uns
sogar ihre überschüssigen Breitbandkabel
schenken in Kigali ist die Verwaltung
weitgehend digital man kann hier eine
Firma am Smartphone Gründen welke ja am
Smartphone das ist Randa Deutschland ist
das
hier
du das macht was aus da hätte ich gar
nicht gedacht oben auf dem Dach da hat
Heiko Terno
Empfang ja ich ahne was sie mein es ist
beneidenswert dass die da in Ruanda auch
ohne Trecker telefonieren können auf der
anderen Seite sagt Human Rights Watch
Journalist Oppositionelle leben
gefährlich in Ruanda
Entschuldigung Ruanda hilft jetzt
ausdrücklich kein Witz als neuer
Werbepartner und Sponsor einem notorisch
bankrotten Fußballclub namens FC Bayern
Frage wenn es in Ruanda ein Problem mit
Menschenrechten gäbe würde dann ein Ulli
höes deren Geld
nehmen ja
sofort gut war jetzt ein schlechtes
Beispiel trotzdem Randa kann noch so
viel für uns tun und die Asylbewerber
die sind ja nur der Anfang die haben
schon angeboten der Bundeswehr Munition
zu schicken die Fragen braucht ihr
vielleicht ein neuen Verkehrsminister
ruft einfach an also ich weiß nicht das
klingt alles irgendwie zynisch okay
anderes Beispiel Deutschland überaltert
hier sind 40% der Bevölkerung unter 15
deshalb sagt Randa schickt uns jederzeit
deutsche Rentner ohne Betreuungsplatz
und soll ich ihnen was sagen heute sind
schon die ersten in Kigali
gelandet was sagen Sie jetzt
okay jetzt bin ich für den randaap
Alexander vielen
Danker
ausali jetzt alle unsere Probleme l so
jetzt aber mal richtig gute Nachrichten
die Länderchefs und Olaf Scholz haben in
ihrer schon erwähnten Nachtsitzung
beschlossen das Deutschland Ticket
bleibt und diesen Jubel ich sofort
wieder zurück den wie das Ticket
finanziert wird weiß leider kein Mensch
ja niemand weiß
das bis Ende 23 teilen sich Bund und
Länder die mehr kosten danach werden
letzte unverbrauchte Bundesmittel
verballert und dann müssen die
Verkehrsverbünde sehen wie sie klar
kommen deshalb geht man noch davon aus
dass das Ticket spätestens im nächsten
Mai teurer wird Problem laut einer ganz
aktuellen Umfrage sagen 37% der
Befragten 49 € seien ihre Schmerzgrenze
Volker wiss ist trotzdem total happy
damit sind jetzt endgültig alle
Finanzfragen geklärt und jetzt geht es
darum dass alle die Debatten über das
Deutschland Ticket einstellen indem das
nicht weiter in Frage gestellt
wird du stellst es doch in Frage Volker
indem du nichts mehr bezahlen willst das
ist so eine Unverschämtheit wenn seine
Ampel erfindet ein deutschlandticket und
dann sollen andere das Bezahlen
tatsächlich haben 10 Millionen Deutsche
eins gekauft 8 bis 10% von denen sind
echte ÖPNV Einsteiger das ist wirklich
ein Erfolg der jetzt aber massiv
gefährdet wird deshalb fragt ein
Bekannter Umweltaktivist auch völlig
zurecht what
about climate
change ganz genau ja what about climate
change ja das war doch eine richtig gute
Frage von Oper Thunberg er hat völlig
recht er hat völlig recht weniger
Emissionen gehen nur mit populärem ÖPNV
und da ist der Preis der Schlüssel die
Menschen haben sich das Ticket ja nicht
gekauft weil damit das Angebot besser
geworden wäre sondern weil es billiger
ist ich sag mal so wenn man sein Auto
stehen lässt ja und stattdessen morgens
bei Hagel und Regen mit dem Fahrrad zum
Bahnhof fährt in der absurden Hoffnung
dass der Zug diesmal pünktlich kommt
oder dass überhaupt was kommt ja dann
muss ich das ja wenigstens finanziell
rechnen der Preis ist der Schlüssel
deswegen ist das Produkt in der Breite
der Bevölkerung so wahnsinnig beliebt
äh das äh Deutschland äh Ticket ähm
nutze ich gegenwärtig
nicht nein hör doch auf wirklich nicht
dabei kann ich mir den Lindner so gut
vorstellen im rappelvollen
frühschichtbus um 6:30 Uhr so der Preis
wird wohl hochgehen und die Beliebtheit
des Tickets wieder runter es werden
wieder mehr Leute morgens ins Auto
steigen also heißt es bald können wir
gemeinsam singen im Wagen vor mir fährt
ein junges Mädchen das hatte bis vor
kurzem noch ein
deutschlandticket ganz toll das zarte
flänzchen Verkehrswende wird direkt
wieder kaputt getrampelt was hat der
wising sich feiern lassen bei Einführung
des Tickets hier vom offiziellen FDP
tiktok Kanal gute Neuigkeiten von
unserem Verkehrsminister volka Wissing
mit dem Wissing Ticket bekommt das 9 €
Ticket endlich einen Nachfolger dieses
ist von nun an papierlos es wird digital
direkt auf dem Handy oder ein Karten
erhältlich sein deutschlandweit die
vielen unterschiedlichen ÖPNV Tarife
sind wir bald endlich los Fazit wising
wirkt ja genau Wissing
wirkt klopptes Internet dämliches tiktok
aber gut machen die jungen Leute halt
heute so hilft ja nichts na habt ihr
euch gerade dran gewöhnt für 49 Öcken im
Monat durch ganz Deutschland zu düsen
war schön ne aber damit ist jetzt
Schluss verdammte schnor
Bande denn ein Verkehrsmittel dass sich
jeder leisten kann geht gegen das
Leistungsprinzip googelt das Wort mal
ihr
loser also zahlt halt mehr oder latscht
zu Fuß zur Arbeit ist ja nur weiß Gott
nicht das Problem von Volker Wissing es
heißt ja nicht umsonst Wissing wirkt und
welke
wirkt
tiktok ja
ich kann einfach alles tragen meine
Damen und Herren als wären die
Verkehrsverbünde in Deutschland nicht
schon genug gestraft zu wenig ÖPNV auf
dem Land andauerndes Problem riesen
Investitionsbedarf nicht zu vergessen
der Fachkräftemangel es fehlen alleine
8000 Busfahrer auch da setzt man in der
Not jetzt zunehmend auf unqualifizierte
Quereinsteiger er hier z.B hat früher
wohl für früher wohl für Hamburger
Banken gearbeitet jetzt macht er elich
mal was sinnvolles es ist wirklich so
schade um das deutschlandticket
andererseits was nützten mir günstige
Rabatte oder günstige Abos wenn hier
demnächst sowieso kein Zug mehr fährt
der Chef der Gewerkschaft deutscher
Lokomotivführer Klaus weselski hält
Streiks in der Weihnachtszeit für
möglich die Bescherung verpassen weil
die Bahn Heiligabend nicht fährt wenn es
nach Klaus weselski geht droht genau das
denn Klaus weselski hasst uns meine
Damen und
und er hasst Weihnachten ja Bahnstreik
zu Weihnachten also möglicherweise nicht
an den Feiertagen selbst aber drumherum
weselski will sich auf den letzten
Metern noch mal richtig unbeliebt machen
denn er geht ja nächstes Jahr in Rente
gestern starteten also seine letzten
Tarifverhandlung für die gefürchtete
lockführergewerkschaft GDL darüber reden
wir jetzt mit dem GDL Vizechef mit
Dennis knossalla Knall die Deutsche Bahn
hat sie um einen Weihnachtsfrieden
gebeten gibt's da noch Chance
Weihnachtsfrieden dass ich nicht lache
was hat denn Weihnachten mit Frieden zu
tun einfache Faustregel ob Weihnachten
überhaupt stattfindet entscheidet in
diesem Land immer noch Klaus wieselski
und der hat das Fest für 2023 bereits
offiziell abgesagt es gibt keine
Geschenke keine ganz und Oma bleibt im
Heim
Feierabend verstehe also ich bin ja
grundsätzlich immer pro Gewerkschaft das
Problem ist nur ihr habt halt zwei davon
GDL und EVG so gesehen hat dieser Kunde
hier ja recht auch wenn er sich hinten
raus komisch ausdrückt ich finde es
unverständlich dass eine kleine Gruppe
von Lockführer eine ganze Nation
flachlet ja gerade weil wir so klein
sind ist das eine Leistung versuch mal
eine ganze Nation flach zu legen das ist
tierische Arbeit bestimmt nur hat ja die
Konkurrenz von der EVG gerade erst im
August mit Streiks ganz gute Erhöhung
durchgesetzt unter anderem
2850 € Inflationsausgleich so ihr
fordert jetzt 3000 ach hör mir auf mit
der EVG
arbeitgeberbittel derte kleine Wichte
die sich für ein paar Cent vor den
bössen auf den Rücken werfen wie so
gewerkschaftsnutten wir fordern ja viel
mehr z.B die 35 Stundenwoche bei vollem
Lohnausgleich Klaus weselski ist der
letzte deutsche Arbeiterführer der
einzige der noch weiß wie Klassenkampf
geht unser Management fährt doch gar
nicht Eisenbahn die lassen sich in
großen Autos durch die gegen kutschieren
wie wild gewordene Nieten in
Nadelstreifen keine Verantwortung
wahrnehmen und viel Geld verdienen im
schampusbaden Leben im Elfenbeinturm und
klare Kante zeigen dass wir uns nicht
die Butter vom Brot nehmen lassen und
dann ist jedes mittelrecht sage ich mal
ganz offen ich gehöre nicht zu denen die
wenn sie auf die linke Wange eine
geknallt kriegen die rechte auch
hinhalten da gibt's
zurück ja dann gibt's aufs Maul aber bis
ein het volle Kanne in die Fresse das
ist die einzige Sprache die sie
verstehen dieser Schampo saufenden
vorstatsflinen in ihren Prosecco gefäten
wpols in der vergoldeten Chefetage ganz
oben im Elfen meint ja gut ist
angekommen ist angekommen mit schuld ist
natürlich auch das blöde
tarifeinheitsgesetz von 2015 seitdem
kämpfen kleine Gewerkschaften wie ihr
ständig um neue Mitglieder euch reicht's
ja nicht nur Lockführer und Zugpersonal
zu vertreten nein wir wollen alle die
Kollegen von Bordbistro aus der
Verwaltung beim Gleisbau und irgendwann
natürlich auch alle anderen Berufe die
mit der Bahn fahren Krankenschwestern
Installateure Tischler Metzer Jongleure
pokenspieler Cowboys Astronauten bis die
GTL die einzige Gewerkschaft ist und so
groß dass man sie aus dem weltinsehen
kann ja dann viel Glück für die
Tarifrunde und liebe Grüße Ruhe ich bin
noch nicht fertig wir hören jetzt die
Weihnachtsgeschichte nach weselski was
warum es begab sich aber zu der Zeit
dass ein Gebot von Kaiser Klaus
wieselski ausging dass alle Welt zu
Hause bliebe außer an den höchsten
Feiertag also fuhren Josef und seine
schwangere Frau Maria am Heiligen Abend
mit dem Regionalexpress nach
Bethlehem bei geänderter
Wagenreihung leider wurde der Zug kurz
hinter Nazaret umgeleitet nach
hambestfalen wo er dann mit
Triebwerkschaden liegen blieb und so
wurde der Sohn Gottes also auf gleich s
geboren während Josef sich in ein
endlosen Schlange vor dem sixchalter
anstellte frohes Fest allerseits von mir
auch Dennis knossaller vielen
[Applaus]
Dank haud die Leute ich wollte euch nur
um ein kleines Abo bitten einfach
anklicken macht's gut na los na los du
scheißpferdy
e